-Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actress
you know and love
from films such as "Bad Moms,"
"Step Brothers," and
"How to Lose a Guy in 10 Days.
She's starring in
Marvel's "WandaVision,"
which is streaming on Disney+,
with new episodes
airing on Fridays.
Let's take a look.
[ Knock on door ]
-[ Snaps fingers ]
Hi, Agnes. Come on in.
I'd get up, but I just --
I just don't want to.
[ Chuckling ]
[ Sighs ]
-I think I got there
in the nick of time,
because she was one split en
away from cutting her own bangs.
-Please welcome back to the show
one of our favorites,
Kathryn Hahn.
How are you, Kathryn?
-Hi, dear. How's it going?
-It is going so well.
I only am upset that you'r
not here in person.
Kathryn,
I love this show so much.
I was so excited
to see you in it.
And then every single episode,
we get to see more from you,
more moves from you,
more is revealed about you
Are you having as much fun as it
is to watch you on the show?
-Yeah, I mean,
the pleasure right now
is watching it with my kids,
who kind of knew, you know
a little bit about it.
Don't tell Kevin Feige,
but [Laughs] I definitely
let them in.
But they -- Just to be abl
to, like, watch it with them
has been such a sweet
Friday-night ritual
that I'm going to be --
I'm already nostalgic
for it to be over.
It's been so sweet.
-So, your kids are at the age --
like 11 and 14?
Is that right?
-Yeah, yeah.
-I also am just nostalgic
at the idea
because I feel like
Friday-night television
was a thing
when we were growing up.
And the idea of, like, watchin
that show with your parents,
when it comes out,
is so exciting,
and it's so cool that you ge
to do it with yours.
-I mean, I remember
watching night,
I don't remember these shows
but it was like for me
it was, like,
"Knight Rider" and "Airwolf.
-Yes.
-Do you remember "Airwolf?
-I do.
Of course I remember.
Borgnine, right?
Ernest Borgnine was in...
-Yeah, and Jan-Michael Vincent
-Jan-Michael Vincent
and Borgnine.
-Yes, and I always, in my mind
have, like, put those shoes --
those shoes? --
those shows together
as, like, for some reason,
they were, like --
it was, like, the car
and the helicopter.
Like, in my mind,
it was like the Love Boat
took people to Fantasy Island.
Like, I made these connections
between the shows.
[ Both laugh ]
But, yeah, exactly.
That was my Friday night.
-Our thing was that we would
watch "Dukes of Hazzard,"
and not one time in the histor
of "Dukes of Hazzard"
did my dad stay awake
the whole show.
-No, sure. No, we called
our TV room, the Fartorium
[ Laughter ]
-So, you -- You know, again,
we talk about it
so much with people
from the Marvel Universe
who come on to promote
those projects.
But what was this like?
Because, you know,
there's so many twists
and turns to your character.
When you're brought in,
do they lay out the whole idea
to you at the beginning?
-Yeah. I mean, for this,
I, like, I walked in --
I mean, I was led into
a conference room,
like, through various -- it felt
very like, in my mind,
you had to use,
like, your thumbprint
to get into certain --
It was very, very
inner -- inner world.
And then you opened the door
to this conference room,
and they had, like,
all over the walls,
like, basically the entire -
the entire story.
The entire series
was, like, laid out.
And they had to walk me
through it a couple times
because I was a little bit
of a newbie to this world.
-[ Laughs ]
-They're very patient.
But, yeah, it was like --
it was just --
I was, when I got to here,
I was playing, like,
a powerful witch.
I was like, "Yes!"
I was so excited.
I was so thrilled.
--Well, you know, again,
I know you as someone
who's really funny.
And in the beginning, I thought,
"Oh, Kathryn's perfectly cas
for this,
because she's going to nai
all these sitcom tropes."
And then the really fun thin
is seeing this villainous side
which I could never have
predicted when it started.
You are playing this character
from the Marvel Universe -
Agatha Harkness, who's a witch
And was witchcraft something -
Did you have any base coat
I know you didn't have muc
for Marvel Universe.
Did you have any base coat
for, like, Salem witchcraft?
-We definitely visited Salem
Not related to this,
but my husband and I
took a road trip there.
And I remember being,
in my mind,
being struck by the fact
that one of the first hangings
was, like, now the site of
like, a 7-Eleven or something.
I remember, like, wishing
there had been
a little bit more reverence.
-Almost every Dunkin' Donuts
in Massachusetts,
that's where a witch was hanged.
-Right, at Dunkin' Donuts.
Right, exactly.
That's exactly it.
I was like, "Why?
They couldn't -- like,
a little bit more?"
But, yeah, I mean,
I think the metaphor of, like,
just, like, a powerful,
complicated, mysterious,
like, terrifying woman
is right up my alley, for sure
-It is.
-I don't mind a tarot card
every once in a while.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
Have you ever gotten
your tarot cards read?
-Yeah, lots.
I do it myself sometimes.
-How would you say,
like, overall,
looking back,
stepping back from it,
what has the level
of accuracy been,
whether an expert was doing it
or yourself?
-Or myself?
I mean, I feel like
you kind of take what you --
You kind of, like --
I don't know if it's accurat
or if it's just, like, a littl
like, thing to think about
for, like, the rest of the day
Um, uh...
-Have you ever done it
for your kids?
Have your kids ever
asked you to read --
-No.
-Okay.
Why is it so crazy?
-[ Laughs ]
Because they would start
laughing hilariously at me
I think they would
be like, "Mom..."
Mom's already, like --
I mean,
when I was practicing my moves
for this particular show,
I mean, my children, like,
came in and saw me practicin
and it just as if
they had seen me
just get out of the shower
Like, they literally were like
"Oh, my God! Mom!"
Like, I was practicing
my witch moves,
and they were so embarrassed
[ Snickers ]
It's, like, I'm just so glad
that now they're suspiciousl
a little bit nicer to me.
So I know that it's been landing
a little cooler
than I had thought.
-That's so funny to think of
when your --
And again, of course,
teenagers especially
are, by nature, judgmental
And as an actor, you have to not
judge your own performance
Right?
I mean, you have to judge it
but you have to really --
and it must be so hard
to watch a teenager,
like, look at you askance
and then have to go
do it professionally.
-Yes. Yeah.
It sure gives you
a lot of confidence.
A lot of self-confidence whe
you're doing it in the mirror.
-But your kids did help lay ou
the Marvel canon
for you a little bit.
Is that true?
-They did, yeah.
I was able to do a deep dive
on Agatha Harkness,
but I definitely needed
a little bit of help with
The Avengers and going backwards
because it was a little bit of
a word salad, walking into this.
I couldn't remember who is who
and what was what.
And so they were --
my son
especially was,
like, a huge, huge help.
-And then your son actually ha
a helpful prop for you,
which must have been nice for...
He did. Do you want to see it?
-Yeah, let's see it.
Wow.
Looks like -- It's beautiful
-Thanks.
-So, you had purchased tha
for him, or is that made?
Is that homemade,
or is that a purchase?
-No, this was -- You know what
Actually, I think --
if you can -- I think
either we put on gems
that we have had to re-hot-glu
on a few times.
And a couple are
clearly missing.
But this was an item of
great reverence in our house
in my son's room,
for a very long time.
Not anymore, he wants to
make sure everybody knows.
But this was kind of my --
This was kind of my entrance
-Well, that's a big deal.
The very fact that you had tha
in your home proves
that this was all meant to be.
-I think so, too.
Kind of want to, like, sna
or whatever and
see what happens.
-Is your daughter
the older of the two?
-My daughter is the younger.
She's 11.
-And she's the one who's sort of
behind the fact that you guy
have been very kind
to the animal community
that has needed help
in these trying times?
-Yes, my sweet daughter ha
persuaded my husband and I
to foster kittens
during the pandemic,
which has been
so lovely and fulfilling.
I will never hear my dryer
without litter
rattling around in it.
But it has been
really, really sweet.
And she's working with
this really fabulous shelter
called the Kitty Bungalow,
who we love so dearly.
And the kittens all have
the most amazing --
they must -- just my heart
about thinking of these people
trying to think of names
for all the kittens.
So, they come to us with names
like Lock, Stock, and Barrel
Like, so, all these children
like, they just --
I think they have to come up
with so many names.
But it's been the sweetest
-So, you say 25 --
I'm assuming
you're not fostering
25 kittens at once.
Right?
-They kind of like stop --
-That would be amazing
if we were bordering
on animal hoarders.
No, it's, like,
a couple at a time.
So, like, right now we have two.
We had three -- Yeah, and my -
We always seem
to get the, like --
the like --
How do I say this?
[ Both laugh ]
My daughter always has, like -
you know, it's important
to know what's happening
with their craps.
So she always gives us
the feces report
as we're sitting down to eat
It seems like every dinner
It's, like, we get to know about
Chickpea's stool consistency
which we're very grateful for.
And one of them
came to us
with a prolapsed anus,
which we didn't know
until we put it in the car
which is, I guess, very common
and easily fixed.
But it was certainly
a surprise to all of us.
-Is it, like, as you're
rolling up the window,
the person at the shelter goes
"Just so you know,
it's a prolapsed anus!"?
-Yeah.
They got fine.
And we are happy to do it.
It's, like, they need the help
Thank God.
-You are incredible
for doing it.
It was Agnes -- sorry --
It was "Agatha All Along"
was the song at the end
of two episodes ago.
And it was actually number one
a 47-second song --
number one on iTunes.
-Don't understand it.
I know, it's amazing.
-Top of the charts.
-It's so crazy.
Seth, what's happening?
-You're top of the charts, kid
[ Laughter ]
-I was so...
[ Laughs ]
I was also like, "What?"
I don't have social media,
so the whole thing
was, like, filtered down
through, like, all this --
I was like,
"Are you kidding me?"
So funny.
I mean, meanwhile,
outside scooping dog crap,
scooping cat crap.
Like, the whole thing
is so bonkers right now.
-Yeah, I guess
when you're looking
at Chickpea's prolapsed anus
it's hard to put in contex
what a big deal it is.
-It was Bellflower.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, no,
it's totally, totally bonkers.
But also, like, a testamen
to the Lopezes,
who just wrote that crazy,
awesome, delicious 47-second -
I mean, the whole thing
is so bonkers.
-I know you can't
give us spoilers.
We have one episode left.
-No, I will.
-[ Laughs ] Great.
Just tell us,
are our minds gonna be blown
in the final episode?
-I think your minds
are gonna be blown.
I'm very excited.
-I'm very excited, too.
-I think it's gonna be
very satisfying.
-It has been.
I'm very happy
to be living through
this "rehonasance."
Is that gonna take off,
do you think?
-"Do you wanna go
to the 'honasance' fair?"
It's gonna be me
with a giant turkey leg.
-At the "rehonasance" fair
everybody shows up
with two fostered cats.
-Yes.
And just me on a dunk tank
by myself.
-Hey, thank you so much.
I love seeing you, as always
-It's so good to see you.
-Love to your family.
And new episodes
of "WandaVision"
are released on Fridays
on Disney+.